J right now we've only known you so far
as someone who works behind the scenes
behind the camera with the scripts with
the story with all that how is it for
you to star in someone else's
independent film how do you feel about
that terrifying starring in someone
else's film is terrifying but but also
incredibly exciting and you know I've
always been actually shooting all of our
films and people almost like why aren't
you ever in it everyone you know is in
your films but you know it's it's
literally because i'm looking through
the lens but i'm excited about the
opportunity and it feels very natural
and it feels positive and you know both
of these characters the the nick
character and the Conrad character kind
of two sides of my really good friend
Jay Davis and I know him so well it's so
easy for me to like lock into that and
do that and I'm just really excited to
explore it it's been something that you
know I came up acting in Austin Texas
with my brother mark as well it just
kind of fell into place that I was
shooting and he was acting for a while
so has Mark influenced anything with
this project in terms of you being in
front of the camera did you tell him
about it yeah marks just been you know
he's going to executive produce it with
me and support me through it and more
than anything he's just been super
supportive of me you know trying
something new and kind of coaching me
through the process in terms of getting
this project up and running and and um
you know because he had a lot of
experience acting in executive producing
movies and so he's been great about it
and you know just honestly believing in
me and and that's that's everything what
advice would you give to actors working
with directors let's suppose or someone
fresh off the bus from somewhere else in
the country what would you tell them
about what it's like to be on set how
they should conduct themselves is it
okay to give unsolicited feedback I mean
what now how should someone be on set
for actors working with directors I
would just say for every everyone on set
in terms of the creative positions just
just to be really honest and open and
vulnerable and express your fears and
and and and and but also to try to be
courageous and bring your best you know
I mean it's it's like the deepest tenets
of making art you just have to do it
socially and publicly when you're making
a film which is which is hard you know
but that's that's all I would say
you